quite frankly how many times have we
been here before I think you and I have
had this very interview you've been
several times it's exactly the same as
Rwanda isn't it the the scheme to deport
people against their will to a different
country you know they have these
headlines all people won't like you but
we're going to crack down right what
happens nothing happens situation
usually gets worse why because they
don't tackle the real problem which is
Criminal gangs exploiting people they go
for the people being exploited rather
than the criminal gangs behind it and
they do not sort out the core of the
issue which is they don't process Asylum
claims with any kind of timely Readiness
I mean I think two percent of the claims
lodged last year currently being
processed for Albanian uh people around
from Albania one percent that's not good
enough and I just wish the one thing
they ever threatened us with is
competent government you know they don't
threaten us with actually tackling the
issue and until they do that I feel
we'll be in this cycle maybe forever
till this government ends I think I'm
writing saying the highest number ever
of migrants who were claiming asylum in
the United Kingdom was what under a
labor government yes but we processed
the claims and where people are not
haven't got a legitimate right to be in
the UK they're made to leave the UK and
where people do have that right because
the claims have been processed and we
found that then of course it's right to
offer those people support period of
several years for you to get there well
let's be clear the Asylum system worked
much much better under the last Labor
government than what we have seen I mean
I understand that the the amount of
claims being processed by the home
office is a fraction of the system that
they inherited and I think until they
tackle that issue this is what we will
see we'll just see this story over and
over again rather than tackling things
that would actually make a difference
and that's got to be serious law
enforcement against the criminal guns
they are the people exploiting people
and that is what has to happen would you
support the use of disused cruise ships
and disuse military
camps in order to House people like that
the crucial thing is that the system
should work so there isn't a need to
House people in any sort of hotels
if that's being used as a threat as a
punitive threat role than an effective
system to actually work out who should
be in the UK and who shouldn't be I'd
have some concerns about that but until
the government recognized that what you
need is a system but first of all you
can return people who shouldn't be in
the UK there's no point threatening
people with anything because what they
end up doing is putting people in hotels
at huge cost and this would be a cost as
well this is part of it they've got to
tackle the real issues rather than this
cycle of threatening punitive measures
against people who are in themselves
very vulnerable and never getting to the
bottom of it and frankly three months
six months we'll begin here having this
interview and they'll come up with some
other idea to get different pages but
they won't have tackled the problem okay
Sue gray a lot of my viewers this
morning will be saying who is she we
know who she is because she uh brought
down the Prime Minister obviously it was
hosted by his own batard but her report
did not help and now she's potentially
going to be the chief of staff for the
next prime minister
um smells a bit fishy to some oh I don't
think it does I think first of all we in
the labor party to take our
responsibility very seriously that's to
prepare as best we can for the next
election and the chance to replace the
government we take nothing for granted
we want the best people working for us
now Boris Johnson was brought down by
Boris Johnson and his own behavior
nobody else is to blame sugary wasn't
even the first person asked to do this
inquiry if we remember the first person
asked to do it had to recruse themselves
because they'd been at the parties they
were supposed to be investigating so I
don't accept any of that I understand
there are legitimate questions and
interest in in the timing and in the
process of that because of the high
profile nature of that report okay in
time all of that will be in the public
domain but what we're trying to do at
the minute is respect the process it's
quite common for civil servants to take
on the jobs we've got to respect that
process that's the this a cobra
committee which looks into these
appointments and decides
forward advisory committee of business
appointments and it is meant to provide
advice before a job is accepted
apparently a cobra has not received a
require a request for advice ice yet
well all of that will be in the public
domain in time we are trying we are
trying to respect this process we didn't
put this information in the public
domain it wasn't the lead party that was
it was an exclusive by Sky News well
exactly you've got very good journalists
sometimes you find things out that you
know you didn't want us to know well you
were going to say you didn't want us to
know that we wanted to follow the
process as you've correctly said whereby
if you're recruiting somebody of a rank
of a position in the Civil Service like
this that is done before it would
ideally be in the public domain that's
the correct process we're trying to
respect that we understand the interest
in it this is an extremely capable
I think there's a public interest but
we're trying to follow exactly we're
trying to follow that process that
exists and this will all be in the
public domain in time but quite frankly
this is simply about the labor party
trying to attract the best people to
work for us and any conservative trying
to you know run away from their own
responsibilities as to what their
government
civil servant obviously because she
wants to work for the labor party now
and she brought down a conservative
prime minister she didn't bring down a
conservative pregnancy but she was
involved in a report suitcases of
alcohol
I don't know it's too great personally I
hear incredibly good things about her
for a professionalism for her Integrity
for a competence of course we want to
build this Coalition of everybody who
wants better for this country than
they've had for the last 13 years under
this government we want to attract the
best people to work for us to take that
seriously and we'll follow the right
process to get those people when did she
first start talking to your leader that
will all be in the public domain it'll
all be in the public domain in time but
that is not for me to get I'm not going
to get into the time frame because that
means we do know that wouldn't respect
the process because West Street had sat
there yesterday he didn't know well it's
not about what people individually do
leader obviously no well I wouldn't say
that I think we're all a team in the
shutter cabinet working together but
fundamentally this is about what's
trying to respect the process which
exists it will not reflect Wellness if
we put it into the public domain
information which are called once and
asks to follow in the usual way and
that's all this is and I think any
concern from people you just can't
except that this is not about them this
is just about the labor party trying to
attract the best what if she can't
accept the job for two years because
she's prevented from doing that it
potentially up to two years she could be
told that she can't have the job and
then she can take it too late then
because you're already potentially in
number 10. top potentials there wasn't
there we take nothing for granted and
I'm not going to second-guess the
decisions that they make we've tried to
attract the best people we think we've
got someone here who is of the caliber
this country needs in a position of
responsibility will follow the correct
process to make that appointment if it
proceeds in the way that we want it to
be okay it's good to see you as always
thanks so much indeed thanks a lot